[Music]
starting off this hour's david in boise
idaho hi david how are you
hey fellas how you all doing better than
we deserve sir how can we help
um so my question comes i'm looking for
some advice
so i'm in this eight-year beautiful
relationship with
the woman of my dreams and
she's very much the free spirit and i'm
very much the nerd and i'm trying to
reel all of that in
i've got the bug for
getting debt free i think we've
accumulated
probably about 60 000 in debt we both
you know i think we're bringing about 10
000 months
but she's an in the moment person so and
i'm trying to
she wants me to do it first
and then she'll jump on board once she
sees
me start tackling it and then she said
she will join me but
i'm finding that very frustrating in the
sense that
she'll blow through some paychecks and
then i'm dipping more into my budget
than
than i need to be doing so
i guess my question would be
how do i how do i i mean is that
possible because i find it it's just
frustrating and it's causing more fights
than anything
how old are you
uh we're both 38. okay
all right
well um let me first uh let's reset the
stage there's not a we you're not
married
right
you're having an argument with your
roommate about how your roommate handles
money
and that's that's a that is a relational
problem but it's also a financial
problem because it's very very difficult
to
pretend like you're married financially
when you're not because the whole
dynamic has shifted
because there's all the legalities
involved um you know there's no there's
no incentives involved you're still just
shacking up and you're 38 years old
and so you're gonna you're really going
to struggle trying to pull this together
and act like it's marriage when it's not
i'll just tell you from 30 years of
coaching people that's the truth and i'm
not trying to pick on you or tell you
you're doing something wrong i'm just
telling you it's a very difficult
dynamic to pull off
um
so what i would do is um
eight years is you know you're asking us
what we would do here's what we would do
here's what we tell you to do if you're
a son i've got a i've got a daughter
your age if you're my son i would say
here's the thing to do eight years long
enough time to paint or get off the
ladder
you know
you know you need to decide whether this
is real whether it's going to go forward
or not we're not just shacking up for
sex now this is a real thing
and so we got to make a call here uh
that's what i would tell my son if he
asked me and um and he was your age and
so
you're going to struggle to prosper
relationally until you make that call
and you're going to struggle to prosper
financially and with the arithmetic
while you're trying to make that call
because she's legally got a set of
responsibilities you legally have a set
of responsibilities and they legally are
not combined
the law all of the people you do
business with everyone recognizes you
only as two individuals instead of one
household unit and yet you use the words
we
like your income is somehow combined it
is not
you have zero legal access to each
other's income at this stage of the game
so that's what i would tell you to do
number one number two then is as a part
of that process
get some good pre-marriage counseling
and start to work on these differences
in your identities and in the way you're
approaching money there's nothing wrong
with one of you being a free spirit and
one of you being the nerd as a matter of
fact that's most couples that have
successful marriages they learn to
navigate all of that but when we as a
husband and wife have a vision for the
future and we are committing to becoming
and staying debt-free so that we can
travel the world buy nice cars be
unbelievably generous and retire with
dignity change our family tree then we
need to stick to the plan that we both
agreed to but there's not a we right now
yeah and i'm going to go back to
something you said david david dave gave
you the fatherly advice i'm gonna be
your big brother for a moment uh
you said that her response to this was
well i want to see you do it see you
live out the baby steps
and then i'll get on board so my quick
question i got a couple things here
are you living it out are you attempting
to do it with your paycheck
yes and so she's seen you do it she's
seen you do it for how long
i've been going steady for about six
months okay so for six months
right so she's seen you do it for six
months and she's still on the sidelines
as your older brother for just this call
i have some real concerns here because
the woman of your dreams
could be the woman of your nightmares if
she doesn't get on board here and i
appreciate what dave is saying but i to
tell you
i would be having a serious conversation
uh before you decide to get married even
before you go into premarital counseling
and i think it comes down to this i
think you got to stop trying to convince
her
and i think you got to harness
her dreams in this conversation and cast
some vision
and and it's a simple construct hey
here's
the problem in the way that you're
living with your money this is what it's
going to lead to this is what it's
gotten you to here's the solution this
process i've learned over here and if we
do this
it's going to give us financial peace
and then our dreams can be bigger than
ever and we can do this dave i got to
tell you i want him i want to know if
she's going to catch this vision before
they even
get serious about marriage because that
really concerns me because of the the
rate of divorce you know if she can't
get on board with this yeah you got well
that's what i'm saying in pre-marriage
counseling yeah or some other way you've
got to get on the same page um or this
is going to end poorly because by the
way it's going to end poorly anyway
that's right if we don't fix this
it's just going to be an ugly breakup
that's correct you know and now we're
going to be fighting over who gets the
mustard because we got confused about
who had who what where the condiments in
the refrigerator came from you know i
mean mayonnaise is mine dead gummy and
so you know i mean that that's what you
that's how you fight with your roommate
you don't end up fighting with your
spouse that way that's right it's a
different fight with your spouse so yeah
you you guys need to be going okay where
do we want to go
financially with our lives and what is
the best route to get there
not
i'm your daddy and you need to behave
yeah not you have to prove it to me
because i don't think you can do it and
i think this is unrealistic and i think
you're going to fall off the wagon and
then i'm going to have an excuse to not
follow through
instead look at it and go as a couple
where do we want to be in 40 years
and what are our steps to get there
i did pick 40 years not so randomly
yesterday was my 40th if you haven't
seen the picture go to dave's instagram
account it is
she's personally beautiful she's
absolutely a beautiful woman now but i
mean and the amount of hair you had i
was the ass guy i was a pretty good
salesman i'm just saying that's all i'm
just saying and so yeah but i mean can
you imagine all the stuff we've been
through two hillbillies fighting for 40
years oh my god brutal this is the
ramsay show